welcome back i will be eating turkey in
a little over an hour and i want to work
up an appetite so i will move forward
and continue with the sat problems
today's thanksgiving by the way that's
why i'm a little extra excited about the
turkey
problem number one
oh by the way we're on page 47 section 9
of of the
was it called the official sat study
guide
problem number one there is the same
number of boys and girls on a school bus
when it departed from school
at the first
so let's say boys so at the beginning
boys equals girls i don't know if this
is going to be useful for me to write
that but let's let's see at the first
stop four boys get off the bus and
nobody gets on so stop one
stop one so minus four
boys
after the first stop there are twice as
many girls as boys on the bus
so now their girls is equal to two times
two times
the boys
how many girls are there on the bus so
you could almost do this by inspection
but
what you could say is well here
there were the boys is equal to the
girls right
then we subtract
4 from the boy so this b is actually a
different b this is two times
the new one b minus four
why does that make sense
well
we have
we start off with b boys at the first
stop four get off so now there are b
minus four boys and at the end it says
that there are twice as many girls as
there are boys now and b minus four are
the number of boys there are now
so now girls is equal to two times b
minus four but we also know that girls
is equal to this initial b right we say
b is equal to two b
minus eight i just distributed the two
and then if we subtract b from both
sides you get and add eight to both
sides you get eight is equal to
b
and you could have probably thought
about that i mean you didn't have to do
all this fancy algebra you could have
just said well
when four
boys leave i'm left with half as many
boys right because before i had just as
many girls as boys
then four leave and i have half as many
right because now the number of girls is
doubled
so if i have some amount of something
and when four leave i'm left with half
then we know we started with eight so
you could have just done it without the
algebra but this is one way you could
make sure you had the right answer
it probably would have taken you too
long so
the best way might have been just to do
it in your head
alright problem number two
and i will do it in magenta
which of the following is the graph of a
linear function with a negative slope
and a positive y-intercept so i'm not
even going to look at those with their
choices and it'll take me forever to
draw them i'm just going to draw
my own graph that describes what they're
saying
that's the x and y axes
and so they say graph of a linear
function so linear function means it's
going to be a line
negative slope so negative slope means
that it it goes from the top left to the
bottom right right because we move to
the right
the negative slope means that the
graph's going to move down so it's going
to go it's going to be
a negative inclination and a positive
y-intercept so that means it intersects
the y-axis
in the positive
y-area so a suitable line would look
something like this right it would
intersect here and move down so it would
look like this
and if we look at the choices of which
ones do that well d is the only one that
looks like what i just drew so the
choice is d
problem
number three
problem three
refer to the following priceless i guess
for problems three and fours let me draw
the priceless so number
of donuts
doughnuts i can never spell donuts i
always want to write out dough but
anyway doughnuts and then it says total
price
total
it says if i get one donut it's going to
cost me 40 cents
if i get
six doughnuts a box of six it's going to
cost me dollar eighty-nine
and if i get 12 doughnuts it's gonna
cost me three dollars and fifty nine
cents and the question is question
number three
of the following which is the closest
closest approximation of the cost per
donut when one purchase a box of six
well a box of six costs is a dollar
eighty-nine right so it's literally a
dollar eighty-nine divided by six a
dollar eighty-nine
over six and you can eyeball that it's
30 32 it's a little over 30 cents right
it's 30 if it was a dollar 80 would be
30 cents and then you have to have nine
divided by six so it's like 31 and
one-third cents it's approximately 31
cents right and if you look at it they
give you very rough numbers so it's
choice b
and what they want you to do is do this
quickly they don't want you to actually
divide the numbers they want to say well
a dollar 89 divided by 6 is roughly 30
cents and you do that problem really
really fast
now problem number four
we use the same price list
what would be the least amount of money
needed to purchase exactly
21 donuts
well if we want to purchase 21 donuts we
want to get in kind of as big
chunks as possible
so let's see if if we got 12
exactly 21 donuts so i mean it could
have been tricky like maybe 24 donuts
would have been cheaper or something we
want exactly 21. so we want to get you
know one dozen of this because this is
going to be a little under 30 cents per
donut right because 360 would be 30
cents
and then we want to get
one of these
right
and then we want to get let's see six
that would get us to 18
and then we want to get three of these
right
times three
so let's see it would be
six times
whoops it's so it's three times 140
which is a dollar twenty
right plus 189
plus 359
so 9 plus 9 is 18
1 plus 2 is 11 16
and then
and that is choice b
this is for problem number four not
problem number three problem number four
let's move on
and we'll switch colors
i will switch colors number five
i think i'm gonna have to do some
drawing now
the figure above which
which of the following is closest to h
of five yeah i'll have to draw that one
so let me draw the coordinate axes
that's my x-axis
this is my y-axis
let's see the graph does
something
something like this
something like let me let me draw the
markers so all right so this is
and so on and they say 2
and 6 and so on this is
minus 2
minus 4 so on and the graph looks
something like this so let's hit minus
six
let me do a different color
so if we start minus six and then
it crosses it goes like some place
goes like there roughly
then it dips down to like here
and it dips down something like that
and then it
see
this goes restless then it does
something i'm trying to be exact because
this is actually all dependent on the
graph
it's going to be something like that
and they want to know after i've drawn
this graph they want to know what is the
closest to h of 5
h of 5
well this is h of x
this is 5. so h of 5 is just going to be
this point right here
right and if we go
to the left it looks like
well it looks like
right in between two and four right and
what's right between two and four well
three
and it looks even more like that when
you look at it on the graph they drew my
graph you could argue it's close to two
but when you look at the one in the book
you can see that it's close to three
and i have a
minute left so i will do that in the
next video see you soon